é muito boa noite quase a todas EA todos
antes de mais Quero Agradecer o convite
que me foi feito e para estar aqui em
Vila Nova de Gaia e falar um bocadinho
daquilo que nós fazemos lá ali um
bocadinho mais abaixo na perto da Costa
da Caparica o tema desta pede Era
exatamente o infinito e os materiais no
meu ponto de vista não tem limites né
Nem tenho fronteiras e vamos falar um
bocadinho não vou falar se calhar do
ensino infinita infinitamente muito
Pequenino Não vos vou falar hoje do
transístor de papel muito embora aquilo
que que vos vou falar hoje tem também a
ver mas vamos falar de uma outra coisa
que acabou por ter talvez mais
visibilidade se calhar também temos
internacionais vou-vos falar de uma
coisa que é invisível que se chama
a crônica transparente que é uma área em
que nós trabalhamos há alguns anos eu
penso que se lembram ou não sei se todos
viram um filme que apareceu em 2004 do
Steven Spielberg que se chamava maiores
Iva e Portes em que o Tom Cruise
manipulava uma série de mostradores
transparentes mas com a informação
portanto ecrãs mas com a informação lá
entre e bebida isto em 2004 era
impossível passados poucos anos passou a
ser possível e que eu gostaria também de
fazer uma referência porque nós na
ciência por vezes também e eu em
particular somos também influenciados um
bocadinho pela ficção científica esta
meta importante até se recuarmos um
bocadinho da nossa história já o Júlio
Verne tinha imaginado uma série de
coisas escreveu sobre coisas a escala
dele que hoje são uma realidade portanto
da ficção ficção científica também
é muito importante para a área da da
ciência para a área da tecnologia O que
é esta coisa da eletrônica transparente
eletronica transparente não é mais do
que nós colocarmos no mesmo material
propriedades transparentes que são
comuns aos vidros são materiais
isolantes e propriedades elétricas que
são comuns aos metais que são materiais
opacos portanto transparência e
opacidade no mesmo material se calhar
uma coisa um bocadinho difícil ser feita
Mas isso é possível
e nós no laboratório trabalhamos temos
uma filosofia grande que é trabalhamos
com materiais e escolhemos materiais
amigos do ambiente materiais que sejam
abundantes não tóxicos e por sua vez
como temos que processar esses materiais
com uma determinada tecnologia as
tecnologias que utilizamos também são
tecnologias não-poluentes tecnologias
amigas do ambiente e estes materiais que
eu vos vou falar nomeadamente na área da
electrónica transparente tem muitas
vantagens vantagens desde logo a sua é o
seu desempenho elétrico tem propriedades
extremamente importantes porque não se
degradam são até materiais que são
biocompatíveis podem ser utilizados
também aplicações biomédicas e não só na
área da electrónica produção destes
materiais e dos dispositivos é também
relativamente fácil e por último
portanto estes materiais são
transparentes
e as aplicações são muitas são
basicamente na área dos mostradores nos
hoje em dia estamos rodeados de
mostradores planos desde os telemóveis
desde as televisões desde os iPads e
estes ecrãs que nós usamos são a imagem
é formada por Pixel e cada Pixel do ecrã
tem um transistor na parte de trás e é
esse transistor que faz com que o Pixel
abra ou feche ou esteja ligado ao esteja
desligado e é esse conjunto de pixeis
que é comandado por este conjunto por
uma matriz de transistores que faz com
que nós temos as imagens nestas
superfícies nestes processadores os
planos e não aqueles convencionais mais
é muito antigos de tubos de tubo de
raios catódicos hora os esses
transistores que estão por detrás destes
pics as antigamente eram feitos ainda
hoje no material se chama o silício mas
a nova geração de mostradores que vai
utilizar em vez de utilizar
Bom dia dos Cristais líquidos que
basicamente a tecnologia que é usado
ainda hoje a nova tecnologia que vai ser
baseada em objetos que é uma tecnologia
diferente aliás penso que já tem até a
muita publicidade sobre isso tanto a
nova tecnologia de um geradores tem que
ter transistores que vão que vão ter o
que tem que ter um desempenho elétrico
muito superior Os Atuais não tem e só
para vos dar uma ideia da importância
dos mostradores que no fundo e a nossa
interface entre nós os nossos dedos e a
tecnologia portanto nós usamos muito os
dedos anos teclados etc temos aqui uma
imagem só também para vos mostrar a
importância dos vereadores temos aqui
uma imagem da eleição do Papa Benedito
em 2005 e depois em 2013 o atual Papa O
Papa Francisco onde na praça do Vaticano
onde podem ver a importância penso que
as a importância dos displays se isto
sendo na praça do
e durante a eleição do Papa não são
velas pertençam são telemóveis são iPads
só para se ver num espaço de tempo tão
pequeno a importância que a massificação
que aconteceu exatamente na área dos
mostradores e nós hoje em dia temos os
merecedores de muitas formas temos
jogadores que são feitos em materiais
flexíveis que podem ser que se podem
adaptar a uma determinada forma temos em
vez de sermos pôsteres temos aliás mesmo
neste Museu já temos uma série de
mostradores até com propriedades
interativas sempre isto é uma imagem dá
uma fotografia do aeroporto em China e
na Coreia do Sul onde estamos rodeados
não só administradores mas também
demonstrador escuros exatamente para ter
uma maior visibilidade e a já hoje em
dia uma série de produtos no mercado que
contém transistores cujos mostradores e
só estão baseados nesta tecnologia
e em que os transistores não são feitos
de silício são feitos dos materiais que
nós também desenvolvemos aqui aqui em
Portugal e por que que é isso que o que
é possível nós utilizamos materiais
alternativos ao material semicondutor
tão conhecido como é o silício acaba
aparecer o rei de toda de toda a
eletrônica como é que está é é possível
Exatamente porque nós usamos materiais
alternativos materiais que tinham aqui
tem aquelas propriedades que Eu
mencionei no início são óxidos de metais
semicondutores e no fundo nós podemos
dizer que estamos numa época o numa Nova
Era de materiais da eletrônica ou seja
investir estamos condicionados ao
silício e outros materiais
semicondutores cuja tecnologia de
processamento é extremamente poluente
daí toda esta indústria da área da
microeletrônica ser deslocado para a
Ásia nós trabalhamos com materiais
alternativos à base de óxidos metálicos
óxido de cobre óxido de zinco óxido de
índio materiais que são abundantes
o que não são tóxicos e estes materiais
são materiais tão simples nós todos
todos os exames já utilizamos Quando
vamos à praia e nos protegemos com
protetor solar se repararem para a
composição do protetor solar ele é um
dos ingredientes e n&o é este está óxido
metálico semicondutor e que nós usamos
exatamente para fazer transístor ou seja
para fazer aquela electrónica
transparente que eu fiz falei no início
exatamente estes materiais
semicondutores e neste caso usados na
área da cosmética ou mesmo usar o ebute
sofremos de Nutella utilizam estes estes
materiais porque eles têm propriedades
muito boas do ponto de vista da
cicatrização nós tem uma particularidade
que a nanoscale e vamos porém
infinitamente pequeno e eles a nanoscale
que tem películas muito finas eles são
transparentes temos aqui uma imagem com
o logotipo da faculdade de ciência e
tecnologia tem que temos ele uma série
de leds são os lados que formam aquela
as letras numa placa de vidro e nesta
placa de vidro nós não temos fios
metálicos Ou seja a corrente chega aos
leads através de pistas através de
materiais a base daquele gênio nós
usamos com protetor solar e que é
transparente mas que simultaneamente é
condutor ou seja este material este DNA
ouviste este material este óxido
metálico tem a propriedade de ser
simultaneamente transparente e condutor
semicondutor neste caso Isto é um
exemplo de um ecrã flexível baseado
nesta tecnologia que foi desenvolvido
através no âmbito do projeto europeu
toda a parte do endereçamento toda
aquela Matriz contra cestas foi feita no
nosso laboratório nós enviamos isto para
um laboratório DNA na Holanda e eles
fizeram toda a parte da da montagem com
com o tal mostrador a base de LED
o tanto isso aqui é um vídeo que não
funciona este meu trabalho teve também
eu ganhei uma bolsa em 2008 do Conselho
europeu de investigação é passado Suzano
100/2011 Este trabalho que foi baseado
na área da eletrónica transparente foi
considerado uma uma história de sucesso
e temos trabalhar desde 2008 com a
Samsung a Coreia do Sul exatamente nesta
área portanto em toda esta tecnologia
demonstradores da nova geração aulete a
um bocadinho a parte de tecnologia
portuguesa está encorporada exatamente
nesta área só para ajudar também o
exemplo da importância dos dos
mostradores por exemplo os telemóveis
temos aqui a evolução dos telemóveis no
início telemóveis eram muito grandes
agora continuam a ser muito grandes mas
prepararem para uma coisa o ecrã era
muito pequenina e neste momento é o
próprio ecrã que limita o tamanho do
telemóvel isso só para mostrar mais uma
vez a importância
e os mostradores na nosso dia a dia e
importância dos transistores que
alimentam aqueles pixies e que formam a
imagem no transportador Portanto o
impacto desta área é extremamente
importante e sei que só mostra a
quantidade de artigos científicos que
tem sido publicada ao longo dos anos
nesta nesta área e é evidente saques
fizemos algumas projeções que que já
estão feitas na área mesmo da
electrónica transparente portanto é um
mercado que vai continuar a crescer
tentar crescer muito e vai crescer
exatamente muito porque a quantidade de
dispositivos que nós usamos que
incorporam esta tecnologia é muito
grande e no futuro não só nos telemóveis
ou nos computadores mas nós podemos
utilizar esta tecnologia transparente
por exemplo no Autocarro podemos ter o
GPS embebido no parabrisas do do nosso
telemóvel ou ter Outras aplicações mesmo
na nossa casa em que podemos utilizar
esta electrónica seja
a tônica propriamente dita seja sensores
a base de destes materiais e que o
exemplo portanto mesmo na parte da
indústria automóvel e hoje em dia em
veículos autônomos em que nós podemos
usufruir e tirar benefícios de todas as
superfícies vidradas que temos em nosso
redor e incluir nessas superfícies de
vidro nessas janelas para que elas não
deixam de ser janelas não deixam de ter
a sua função mas tem um valor
acrescentado com com toda a informação
que nós lá podemos colocar isso imagens
já um bocadinho futuristicas mas no
futuro eventualmente podemos os nossos
computadores poderão ser qualquer coisa
deste deste tipo e mais uma vez o ano
passado também esta área foi destacada
pela comissão europeia e foi atribuído a
este trabalho na área da eletrónica
transparente o prêmio do Riso Impacto
Wars Mas como já foi dito também no
início desta ted's tem um time work
portanto Isto é um trabalho de equipa e
sem ti
e não chega a lado nenhum e isto é a
equipa parte da equipa deste grande
Instituto que junta os materiais da
Universidade nova de Lisboa com a parte
da Física da Universidade de Aveiro e
também é isso já foi dito hoje portanto
se quiseres ir chegar depressa vai
sozinho se quiseres chegar longe vai
acompanhada e nós podemos chegar andar
acompanhados muito obrigada
[Aplausos]